[Musik]
hey lieben dieses video wird mich allen
studentinnen und studenten da draußen
die im studentenwohnheim keinen ofen
haben oder auch all diejenigen die mal
den ofen aus lassen möchten wenn wir
machen heute kekse die ganz ohne
backofen auskommen und die ihr sogar
vegan ii sieren können falls da das
interesse besteht zeigt euch hier einmal
die zutaten für unsere kokos für moment
niemand so ganz nebenbei bemerkt sind
das coco schokokekse wir machen wir
zuallererst diesen cocos grießpudding
mal der ein bisschen auskühlen muss also
ein paar minütchen und daher gehen wir
jetzt einfach sofort hier sind die
zutaten benötigt natürlich kokosraspeln
dann habe ich hier zucker und weizen
gries mutter da könnt ihr gerne
margarine verwenden und milch da könnt
ihr dann wahlweise pflanzen milch
verwenden jetzt geben wir alle zutaten
bis auf die kokosraspeln einmal in den
topf lassen das aufkochen unter
ständigem rühren das dürfte nicht
vernachlässigen und dann liegt das ganze
auch schon allem wir hatten schön
grießpudding und dann gehen die
kokosraspeln dazu
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann die kokosraspeln dazu
gibt einfach dem herd ausschalten das
ganze verrühren und an die seite geben
die mass ist hier auch richtig schön
fest geworden
wir geben das ist es wirklich nur für
ein paar minuten an die seite und ich
zeige euch jetzt die äußere schicht dass
es unser keks mantel und wir haben am
ende dann eine rolle die wir dann
durchschneiden ihr habt dann richtig
schön oder kekse aber ich quatsch nicht
viel drumherum ich zeige es euch lieber
ich habe jetzt hier die vier zutaten die
wir dafür benötigen
das sind einmal butterkekse die habe ich
schon klein zu häckseln also je feiner
desto besser ihr könnt auch vollkommen
wirklich zu nehmen wenn ihr möchtet dann
habe ich hier noch etwas puderzucker
ganz gewöhnliche milch da könnte jetzt
auch wieder wie gerne milch alternativen
nehmen und etwas bei kaka nimmt er auch
den starken töten und nicht den trinker
kaum
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die butter keksen eine
große schüssel gegeben puderzucker und
bei cacau hinzu gesiebt also wenn ihr
das ganze sieht können wir natürlich
verhindern dass der klumpen drin sind
und das ganze verbindet sich einfach
viel besser und jetzt gibt ihr nach und
nach dem milch dazu benutzt eure
sauberen finger um das ganze zu
verstehen dann habt ihr einfach ein
besseres gefühl dafür und den teig muss
dann so sein dass er wenn ihnen
zusammenrollt schön zusammen bleibt und
auch nicht brüchig ist aber das zeige
ich euch jetzt
[Musik]
das ist jetzt die konsistenz also fest
nicht zu klebrig gerade richtig dass man
es aus rollen kann und jetzt habe ich
hier vor mir schon auf der arbeitsfläche
frischhaltefolie ausgelegt da werden wir
das ganze gleich einrollen und deshalb
nehme ich mir jetzt diesen teig und gibt
den da drauf und dann rolle ich sie
nicht aus ungefähr 30 mal 20 zentimeter
und dann kommt die kokons schicht
darüber
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann die kokons schicht
glatt verstrichen habt die glatte das
verstreichen so schön das ist ergebnis
wollt ihr das ganze jetzt auch und das
gelingt euch ganz easy mit dem schalter
folie also ganz einfach donau freuen
und dann sind wir auch schon fast fertig
[Musik]
und jetzt muss die keks rolle in der
folie im kühlschrank aus herten damit
wir es auch schöne unterscheiden können
die einzelnen keks schreiben und das
dauert so mindestens vier stunden also
gibt dem ganzen wirklich vier
studienzeit ihr könnt es gerne auch über
nacht machen und dann am nächsten tag
wirklich runter schneiden oder erwartet
irgendwie vier stunden also bis gleich
[Musik]
und fertig das endergebnis kann sich
echt sehen lassen hier sehen so gut aus
und schmecken jetzt so ein bisschen soft
also ihr dürft euch das ist so
vorstellen dass ihr daran beißt und
wirklich die geballte ladung kokos habt
in verbindung mit schokolade was hamza
und mich das haben wir gerade
festgestellt an was erinnert an martin
also werde ich gleich post könnte man
auch party cookies oder bei und die
glich sie falls sie noch andere
vorschläge habt wie sagt man so schön
bis cookie würde jetzt werden jetzt die
anderen schreiben also üblichen mengen
the caption also schreibt mir auch gerne
mal eure titel vorschläge in die
kommentare
und dann schaut gerne in die video
beschreibung für die ganz genauen
mengenangaben vergisst das bäumchen
nicht und wenn ihr mehr so ich habe
praktischen studenten rezepte sehen
möchte dann schreibt man auch gerne mal
euro themenvorschläge auch in die
kommentare lese ich mir ganz fleißig
durch und dann würde ich sagen sehen wir
uns auch beim nächsten mal hier auf
gleich es gibt es im schloss ist es aber
ich habe das aber nie vergessen jetzt
spätestens wenn ihr jetzt noch nicht
ausgeschaltet habt genau dann abonniert
und aktivität auch die glocke dann
bekommt er als allererstes mit wenn ich
neues video hochladen
[Musik]